[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 le journal voici les
titres de l'actualité
dimanche 26 février le lancement de la
campagne présidentielle de benoît hamon
dans les yvelines a eu lieu à la ferme
de bel ébat à guyancourt près de 300
personnes dont des élus socialistes de
la région étaient présents à l'occasion
du salon de l'agriculture qui se tient
cette semaine à paris nous vous
proposons de faire un point sur le
département
le premier épisode de ce dossier
consacré aux jeunes agriculteurs et
leurs difficultés et puis suite aux
images chocs de maltraitance aux animaux
révélée par l'association l214 au sein
de l'abattoir guerra ou dans une
manifestation de soutien a réuni jeudi
23 février plus de 200 agriculteurs
le candidat socialiste à la
présidentielle benoît hamon et son
nouveau soutien yannick jadot ont
effectué aujourd'hui leur premier
déplacement commun un rapprochement
valider ce dimanche par des militants
d'europe écologie les verts à plus de
80% lors d'un référendum sur internet et
dont se félicite le responsable local de
la formation dans les yvelines
olivier paréja espère également voir se
réaliser une union avec jean luc
mélenchon il clair le fait qu elle
benoît montre sortie de la primaire du
parti socialiste changerait absolument
tout nous étions pour une rupture avec
la politique du gouvernement actuel donc
pour nous venoit -47 cette rupture et
jean luc mélenchon a dans son programme
aussi des choses très écologiste donc il
ya peut-être moyen de trouver ce socle
qui nous rassemble plutôt que d'inviter
sur les divisions
on a une grosse attente de figure qui a
été négocié soir tubes et continue à
vivre contrairement à ce qui s'est passé
avec l'accord qui avait été passé en
2011 avec le parti socialiste
et on continue avec le parti socialiste
dimanche dernier près de 300 personnes
dont des élus étaient à la ferme de bel
ébat à guyancourt
pour le lancement de la campagne devenu
un monde dans son département les
yvelines plusieurs élus socialistes
yvelinois ont soutenu l'importance de
l'unité à gauche
ils ont aussi profité pour échanger avec
les électeurs sur place un reportage de
nicolas landry unifier la gauche pour ce
lancement de campagne présidentielle
dans les yvelines les socialistes n'ont
pas hésité à marteler ce mot d'ordre
oui j'y crois parce qu'il est nécessaire
indispensable comme l'a souligné michel
pouzol c'est soit ça soit on est mort je
pense que monsieur mélenchon
ne veut absolument pas rejoindre le
parti socialiste dans lequel il a
pourtant militer de nombreuses années
c'est un peu dommage
aujourd'hui on a vu que yannick jadot
avait fait le par vers benoît hamon et
j'espère de tout coeur que jean luc
mélenchon fera aussi le pas vers benoît
hamon afin qu'on ait une gauche unitaire
pour pouvoir gagner faire gagner nos
idées
les verts et le ps est dorénavant main
dans la main une nouvelle largement
commentée ici à la ferme de bel ébat à
guyancourt ce dimanche matin on a
discuté largement et que élevé ghislaine
sénat était là aujourd'hui pour aussi
apporté son soutien à une dynamique à
gauche je rencontre le parti communiste
pour tout vous dire demain donc voilà il
ya évidemment des discussions qui sont
en cours
allier les valeurs socialistes avec les
valeurs communistes front de gauche de
la france insoumise les valeurs
citoyennes et les valeurs écologistes
je crois que ce serait le plus gros un
programme en tout cas et est le plus bel
espoir que l'on peut donner aux français
benoît hamon toujours député des
yvelines pourra compter en tout cas sur
le soutien de sa fédération
dans le département il avait obtenu plus
de 58% des suffrages lors de la primaire
de la gauche
douze jours voici douze jours que mona
juul à minguet habitants de montigny le
bretonneux est porté disparu
son téléphone a été localisé pour la
dernière fois à rambouillet samedi un
rassemblement de soutien est organisé si
vous avez des informations sur cette
disparition
n'hésitez pas à contacter le
commissariat d'elancourt au numéro
inscrit en bas de l'écran
la zone de satory ouest s'agrandit
vendredi dernier la première pierre du
cluster mobilité innovante a été posée
aux manettes de ce projet le conseil
départemental et versailles grand parc
c'est le début du futur quartier mixte
économique et résidentiel qui
accueillera 300 mille mètres carrés
d'activités économiques et 5000
logements
après deux ans de tractations le cluster
a eu droit à la pose de la pro
r pierre vendredi 24 février le cluster
des mobilités innovantes qui sera livrée
en 2018 représentera 6 mille trois cents
mètres carrés de surface sur quatre
niveaux 50% de l'espace sera dédiée à la
recherche à la formation
le laboratoire de recherche d'iftar des
pme de la filière des mobilités et vd
comme cohabiteront dans les locaux nous
serons à proximité des pistes ce qui
permettra également de faire de la
simulation me d'expérimentation sur des
véhicules
il y aura des ateliers également qui
nous permettront de préparer les objets
et
rassembler les industriels ainsi que les
académiques des chercheurs aujourd'hui
il a été prévu pour plus de 200
personnes sur place et qui pourront être
aussi accueillir des
et notamment des start up pour des
chercheurs pour un projet localement et
le nouveau bâtiment sera construit dans
la zone satory ouest à proximité
d'entreprises technologiques et
industrielles telles que nexter renault
trucks defense ou encore citroën racing
le but faire de ce cluster des mobilités
innovantes
la première vitrine économique de la
région
l'étude de la mobilité décarbonée est
automatique est un sujet mondial ou le
premier qui trouvera les solutions
gagnera des marchés mondiaux
le département des yvelines à temps sur
flins menthe renault guyancourt
nous avons poissy avec bessat nous avons
vélizy on voit bien que le département
des yvelines est un département avant
tout automobile mais thermique dès 2018
vd comme recevra les voitures touvier de
renault que l'entreprise rendra autonome
le 6 février dernier versailles a été
choisi comme l'une des six villes
d'europe sélectionnés pour tester ces
véhicules qui circulent en auto pilot le
salon de l'agriculture c'est cette
semaine à paris et pour l'occasion nous
avons décidé de consacrer de faire un
point sur le département
le premier volet de ce dossier est
consacré aux jeunes agriculteurs jeunes
agriculteurs en difficulté c'est un
reportage signé nicolas d'andré
comme chaque matinée d'hiver nicolas
jossier prend son tracteur direction ses
champs de céréales pour contrôler les
semences face aux menaces de la période
hivernale notamment les mauvaises herbes
les insectes ici à un vule pas mais
comme on peut le voir on les a traités à
l'automne et le produit agit là la
plante est en train d'être détruites
pour l'instant l'implantation des
céréales et est excellente donc nous
allons croiser les doigts pour que la
météo soit avec nous et et nous prend
nous procure le soleil et l'eau qu'il
faut pour mener à bien nos cultures en
fait blé orge colza cette exploitation
familiale et basés de plus près d'un
siècle au village de prunes et en
yvelines à 33 ans nicolas chossy a
décidé de reprendre cette ferme qui
s'est installé le 1er septembre 2016 et
souhaite utiliser son expérience
professionnelle dans sa nouvelle
activité
j'ai été boulanger et pâtissier pendant
15 ans tout en travaillant l'après-midi
avec mon père sur l'exploitation pour
lui pour lui donner un coup de main donc
j'ai toujours eu l'amour de de la terre
et de la ferme familiale
j'espère pouvoir me diversifier
justement comment dire en combinant mon
métier antérieures c'est à dire le
métier de boulanger
c'est à dire valoriser mon blé en farine
et enfin classement de factures
signature de documents le travail
administratif est important lors d'une
installation une procédure rendue
compliquée aussi par la conjoncture
agricole les difficultés de prix des
marchés des céréales qui sont qui sont
au plus bas depuis quelques années ce
qui fragilise
comment dire notre notre trésorerie
la moisson 2016 qui a été catastrophique
en tâches encore cette trésorerie
par contre c'est vrai que on peut
compter sur sur nos partenaires
d'approvisionnement
en ce moment sans produits
phytosanitaires en engrais pour nous
aider à traverser cette mauvaise passe
quoi et 2016 n'a pas été favorable à
l'installation des jeunes agriculteurs
certains ont décidé de repousser leurs
démarches
en attendant une période plus stable
pour le secteur agricole
ils veulent sauver le dernier abattoirs
de porcs d'ile-de-france deux syndicats
d'agriculteurs se sont rassemblés jeudi
dernier devant l'abattoir guie guie a
rang de mou dans pour lui manifester
leur soutien
cet établissement est poursuivi en
justice par l'association de défense des
animaux l214 pour maltraitance animale
un reportage de patrick jacques de
dixmude et d'anne laure l'anguille ils
étaient environ 200 selon les
organisateurs une centaine selon la
gendarmerie
des agriculteurs répondant à l'appel de
deux syndicats sont venus manifester
jeudi soir dernier devant l'abattoir de
houdan accompagné de quelques élus
locaux ils dénoncent les agissements de
l'association l214 qui a déposé plainte
contre cet établissement pour
maltraitance animale
ça a démarré d'un père de famille dont
son fils travaille ici qui m'a dit mais
si l'abattoir il ferme mon fils il va
être au chômage comment comment je
commence enfin voila c c c c normal
qu'un père s'inquiète de savoir comment
on veut son fils va finir les fins de
mois les traites de sa maison et des
choses comme ça il y à une quinzaine de
jours l'association l214 diffusé des
images filmées à l'intérieur de
l'abattoir montrant des employés en
train de distribuer des coups aux
cochons pour forcer leur passage vers
l'abattage les images l214 qui m'ont et
v10 effectivement choquer tout a été
fait chez nous pour que ça se reproduise
plus tout était déjà fait mais là on a
mis les bouchées doubles
des promesses qui ne suffiront pas
l'association l214 a annoncé un nouveau
rassemblement de protestation devant
l'abattoir jeudi prochain ce que je ne
peux pas tolérer c'est qu'un groupe qui
a une philosophie particulière qui est
de choisir de ne pas consommer aucun
produit d'origine animale puisse diriger
en une sorte de diktat pour imposer
cette volonté à l'ensemble de la société
l'entreprise avait rencontré des
difficultés au début des années 2000
suite à la crise de la vache folle elle
avait ensuite remonté la pente en
pariant sur le circuit court prisés par
les consommateurs
l'université versailles saint quentin
recevait mercredi dernier le chercheur
américain allen malony au laboratoire de
lits parade
le professeur y travaillera pendant six
mois dans le cadre de la chaire
fulbright un échange universitaire et
culturel pendant six mois
alan malony professeur et chercheur
enseignera à lui vécu grâce à la
commission cher fulbright entouré de
professeurs et de scientifiques
l'américain enseignera l'évolution de la
technologie à versailles
hunting gauche sera soient-elles
j'enseigne mes cours en anglais c'est
une chose et aussi pour les cours en
master sur les hautes performances
informatiques
j'enseigne dans ce programme aux
étudiants de deuxième année en ce moment
je leur enseigne comment faire une
optimisation des performances sur des
eaux processus ou cpu des systèmes
informatiques à la malmö qui enseignent
habituellement dans le département
d'informatique à l'université de
l'oregon restera pour transmettre son
savoir aux étudiants français
un dispositif de collaboration entre les
états unis et la france pour inclure un
professeur étrangers au programme
ça apporte à l'université ben un
chercheur de renommée qui vient pour six
mois et qui peut développer alors il va
nous apporter de manière très
intéressante en termes ce soit en termes
d'enseignement ou de recherche
une autre vision des choses d'une autre
manière tout un réseau grâce à cette
chère le professeur malony aimerez par
la suite entreprendre sur le long terme
un partenariat dans la recherche avec
louvain sq
c'est la fin de ce cette ut le journal
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]